playstation ads are weird so weird that
it can be interpreted as commercial
marketing genius how else do you think
sony's managed to sell half a billion
consoles with its games
sure but more importantly by
subliminally implanting playstation into
your consciousness
with weird ass ads most of which don't
even show its games like the dude
launching into outer space on a boat
or the guy who drowned an entire city
with his tears because norman reedus
hugged a baby
i don't understand them i just nod my
head and say
take my money and with a new era of high
brow ads
most certainly on the way with the
playstation 5 i wanted to look back at
some of the more
inspired playstation ads they've had
over the past
26 years and analyze them with a
critical eye
so here are my top 5 weirdest
playstation ads
you may have forgotten about maybe even
intentionally
[Music]
let's tear the bandage off first up the
baby
ah yes of course aren't we all just
plastic shells gripping onto our
fleeting adolescent-like innocence
coping with abandonment
and loneliness seeking meaning in the
abyss
[Music]
[Music]
next up we have multi-speed or i call
poetry in motion because anything that
uses claire balloon just signifies
that it has deeper meaning a statement
on the speed of life
passing before our eyes as we traverse
it with stillness
day by day stagnant but the world
keeps spinning reminiscent of a great
philosopher who once said
life moves pretty fast if you don't stop
and look around every once in a while
you can miss it or in this case an old
lady can outrun you and
cut your milk
would you mind very much if you just
took your glasses off for a second we
could just see what your eyes look like
uh no i'm off right ah yes jimmy
dynamite the integrity of a gamer uh
empowered by dynamism of interactive
digital fiction
unshaken by other people's demands the
play by your own rules
and the other dude uh is a juxtaposition
of the non-gamer the duality of
cool and uncool just so they can see
what you look like
you're all right okay all right bye okay
if you're like me you saw the apex twin
music video come to daddy and we're
scarred for life well playstation
thought hey let's get that guy who makes
the terrifying affects twitter music
videos that scar people
and get him to do an ad making mental
wealth directed by chris cunningham my
number two let me tell you it bugs me
about human endeavour
land on your own moon it's no longer
about what they can achieve
out there in your behalf but what we can
experience
up here in our own time
it's called mental wealth of course
uh the meaning to this one is quite
obvious
clearly um yeah
[Music]
in 1999 david lynch was hot off the
heels of his only g-rated film
a straight story which is a road trip
movie about an old man
on a lawnmower it was a big success
featuring all the lynchisms like
capturing the cork and charm of
simple rural folk just minus all the
extreme violence strobe lights fog and
screaming
but sony said hey david make an ad
make up for everything the street story
was missing bringing us
to our number one the third place
welcome to the third place
anyways there we have it now that we've
reached artistic enlightenment we can
head into this next generation of
playstation advertising
with a deeper understanding of what it
is that has made its consoles
so damn successful weird
[Music]
you